[Music]
peppermint versus butterscotch candies
hard candy it's it's grandmother's purse
to my mouth from God to God's ears
butterscotch is a flavor of something
has more use to me than peppermint does
like if you gave me ice cream with
butterscotch syrup I'd be like okay this
is pretty good peppermint ice cream I
can't tell you how gross I think that is
it doesn't matter that's literally it
has nothing to do with this battle
peppermint has way more uses of butter I
I disagree because I think any time it
has a Paramount use in my in my opinion
peppermint is a flavor in anything
outside of it mint is gross that's well
it's a good thing we're talking about
mints so butterscotch as a candy has
more sustenance and more purpose than a
peppermint Peppermint's only purpose is
to serve as a breath freshener
why does butterscotch not appeal
to young people and and but peppermint
does though peppermint then appeals to
all ages
I think butterscotch really just doesn't
appeal to younger kids